bienvenue sur lcp public sénat c'est
l'heure de parlement hebdo de santé
ensemble pour 45 minutes pour refaire
l'aktu politique et parlementaire
bonjour michael bonjour coach a est le
temps fort de cette folle semaine
politique c'est bien sûr la déclaration
de politique générale de manuel valls
suivi du vote de confiance une confiance
accordée sur fond de défiance 269 voix
pour et 30 et une abstention socialiste
la majorité est fragilisée quatrième
conférence de presse pour françois
hollande face aux questions des
journalistes le chef de l'état a
longuement évoqué la situation
internationale et économique et une
nouvelle anna fort vous vous souvenez de
blois président cette fois place pour
pas facile au total cette phrase
commençant par cette formule est un
président en cache un autre il ne l'a
pas si tel est son nom était sur toutes
les lèvres est aussi dans les esprits
nicolas sarkozy revient le match retour
est peut-être déjà lancé
et pour commenter cette folle semaine
politique avec nous et andré vallini
bonjour bonjour vous êtes secrétaire
d'état à la réforme territoriale
hollandais historique nous raconterez un
petit peu vous étiez leur présente lors
de cette conférence de presse me dire un
petit peu comment vous avez vécu tout ça
comment vous avez vécu cette semaine
politique mais c'est une tradition dans
cette émission m'a laissé la parole aux
parlementaires qui s'exprime à votre
propos qui voudraient sans quelque sorte
votre porte à écouter
je crois que c'est un homme de qualité
un homme d'expérience c'était un
collègue de très bon niveau
pour le moment c'est vrai qu'on a très
peu vu même dans le débat local dont il
est pourtant chargé donc opinion a
priori positive mais je juge sur les
actes c'est quelqu'un que je respecte
qui à mes yeux est quelqu'un de correct
qui fait son job je partage pas
nécessairement toutes ces idées mais en
tout cas ils occupent dignement les
fonctions qu'il occupe aujourd'hui
réforme territoriale
écoutez j'ai remarqué qu'il est resté
silencieux pendant tout le débat lors de
la première lecture à l'assemblée
nationale ce qui est un avantage pour le
gouvernement d'ailleurs son silence mais
le fait d'être en charge de ces
responsabilités devraient l'inciter à
intervenir davantage il a fait le job en
tant qu' en tant que président de
conseil général il a fait jobs lorsqu'il
travaillait sur les questions de justice
au parti socialiste et je crois qu'il
fait le job aujourd'hui là où il est
andré vallini on va revenir sur le fond
de la réforme ne vous inquiétez pas
là-dessus il n'y a pas de problème mais
quand on entend que vous vous cachez est
ce que c'est vrai face à ce qu'il quitte
en tout cas c'est voulu peut-être donc
j'ai entendu beaucoup de compliments sur
mon sérieux le travail que je fais que
j'ai fait comme député comme sénateur
notamment sur l'injustice dans le je
travaille beaucoup pas forcément en me
montrant à l'assemblée ou au sénat
et seulement pour me montrer non je
travaille beaucoup à mon bureau dans des
réunions au parlement bien sûr en
rencontrant beaucoup de parlementaires
des députés comme dessinateur en les
recevant beaucoup
avant ministère en allant beaucoup aux
provinces je vais beaucoup aux provinces
voire les élus mais pas seulement les
acteurs économiques qui est qui font les
territoires qui font la vie des
territoires je participe à beaucoup de
congrès d'élus du congrès des maires le
week-end notamment
parfois un peu fatigué mais très
intéressant parce que cette réforme elle
demande à être enrichie par ceux qui
sont concernés sur le terrain donc j'y
vais pour expliquer la réforme j'y vais
aussi pour nourrir la réforme on va
revenir sur fond cette réforme mais
quand vous voyez la tâche qui vous
attend c'est un peu les douze travaux
d'hercule est-ce que vous avez pas envie
jeter l'épongé non ce n'est pas ma
nature jeter l'épongé c'est une réforme
difficile c'est vrai et françois
hollande quand il m'a confié cette
mission m'a dit tu vas avoir du travail
et ça ne sera pas facile mais je veux
mais je facile mais je compte sur toi
donc voilà j'essaie d'être à la hauteur
de la tâche qu'il m'a confiées et que
manuel valls a bien voulu me confier
aussi c'est vrai que c'est ton est ferme
difficile je suis d'ailleurs frappé
qu'en france tout le monde est pour la
réforme dans tous les domaines
d'ailleurs mais que dès qu'une réforme
est annoncée
alors l'aller les oppositions se lève
mon servaty soit la france allait
réticents se manifestent les résistances
s'organisent vous savez il paraît que
henri queuille président du conseil de
la ive république ou edgar faure ou les
deux hunger for site henri queuille
disait en france lorsqu'une grande
réforme est annoncée
l'immobilisme se met en marche et rien
ne peut l'arrêter c'est un peu ce que je
vis actuellement c'est à dire que cette
grande réforme qui était attendu par les
français qui est toujours attendu par
les français parce que les sondages le
montrent semaine après semaine les
sondages montrent que les français sont
à 60 70 % favorable à cette réforme
cette réforme qui était attendu par la
droite comme par la gauche voulue par
l'ump comme par parti socialiste parce
que l'ump pendant deux ans nous a dit
vous ne faites pas de réformes
structurelles fait enfin des réformes
structurelles comme ils veulent aborder
cette partie est
lancée sur la réforme beaucoup de choses
à voir
en détail mais d'abord je propose de
dérouler la semaine on commence avec
lundi rendez vous à paris qui a
accueilli les ministres des affaires
étrangères pour une grande conférence
internationale sur l'irak
une trentaine de représentants de pays
occidentaux et arabes étaient réunis
autour de françois hollande pour donner
un feu vert politique à la lutte contre
les djihadistes deux dash la france sera
l'une des têtes de pont de la coalition
internationale qui se met en place aux
côtés des états unis on reviendra sur
cette conférence pendant ce temps à
l'assemblée le ministre de l'intérieur a
présenté un projet de loi pour lutter
contre les filières terroristes objectif
dissuader les jeunes ressortissants
français tentés par le combat en syrie
de partir jérémie hoffmann
principal dispositif du texte pour
empêcher les candidats au djihad de
partir en syrie ou en irak la création
d'une interdiction administrative de
sortie du territoire avec retrait de
passeports et de cartes d'identité quand
il existe des raisons sérieuses de
penser qu'un citoyen français envisage
de rejoindre ces zones de conflit
empêcher les départs et mieux surveiller
les retours car le phénomène du
jihadisme le français prend de l'ampleur
encore récemment le terrorisme était
réservée à une poignée d'individus
aujourd'hui le terrorisme est devenu en
libre accès l'objectif du projet de loi
est aussi de mieux déceler ces loups
solitaires même si l'expression ne plaît
pas au ministre de l'intérieur
car ces personnes sont souvent en
relation avec des mouvances très
organisé une nouvelle incrimination
d'entreprise terroriste individuelle est
créé partant du principe qu'un acte
terroriste peut être commis sans qu'il y
ait forcément un ordre de mission à
l'origine enfin le texte prévoit le
blocage administratif de certains sites
internet faisant l'apologie ou incitants
à l'action terroriste les éditeurs
hébergeurs de ces sites auront un délai
de 24 heures pour retirer les contenus
incriminés avant un éventuel blocage
andré vallini que change ce texte est ce
qu'une simple mesure administrative pour
vous va vraiment dissuader les jeunes
français tentés par le combat en syrie
de partir c'est une mesure
administrative peut-être mais qui sera
efficace en tout cas je l'espère tout le
monde est conscient du danger que
représente le djihadisme dans les pays
où ils se développent mais aussi dans
nos propres pays
d'europe occidentale notamment tout le
monde connaît maintenant le problème que
posent ces jeunes
français notamment mais c'est le
problème est le même dans d'autres pays
qui partent faire le djihad il concerne
surtout la france comment vous un seul
rond pas seulement et beaucoup hier le
prison la république dans sa conférence
de presse a parlé du témoignage que
qu'il avait qu'il avait recueillie
auprès d'un premier ministre irakien qui
lui disait qu'il y avait dans un char
qui avait été neutralisé un char
jihadistes en irak qu'il y avait un vent
russe
un onglet enfin y avait quatre
nationalités en allemand on est nous
sommes tous touchés donc il faut prendre
des mesures d'autres pays ont pris déjà
des mesures nous les prenons dans le
respect des libertés fondamentales des
droits fondamentaux de la personne
humaine mais il faut prendre des mesures
que vous êtes sûr que c'est faute de
lois répressives que ça rejoindrait bdd
mohamed messaoud et mehdi nebbou ces
photos gaulois parfois de lois
répressives ses fautes sans doute de
surveillance suffisante
nos services sont mobilisés ils ne sont
plus encore qu'il ne l'était jusque là
d'ailleurs lors de la dernière réunion
du gouvernement à matignon
manuel valls jeudi matin nous a dit à
quel point la menace terroriste est
prégnante uns et pas seulement en france
donc tous les services sont mobilisés
mais nous avions besoin de moyens
juridiques supplémentaires pour empêcher
des jeunes d'être embrigader enrôlé dans
le jihad on arrive au mardi il était
attendu et redouté pour certains le
premier ministre a demandé la confiance
sans surprise ou presque le gouvernement
a obtenu la confiance mais avec une
majorité beaucoup plus étriqué dans son
discours plutôt offensif manuel valls a
dû donner quand même des gages à sa
gauche on voit ça avec sophie normand
c'est un premier ministre combatif qui
pendant 46 minutes s'est adressé aux
députés
gouverner c'est tenir gouverner c'est
réformer gouverner c'est dire la vérité
gouverner mesdames et messieurs les
députés c'est aller chercher la
confiance surtout quand c'est difficile
pour l'obtenir il lui a fallu convaincre
sa majorité
vérité égalité justice c'est bien à elle
qu'il s'adresse lorsqu'il se réclament
des valeurs chères à la gauche elle est
toujours dans son viseur quand il manie
l'anaphore il n'y aura pas de remise en
cause des 35 heures ni de la durée
légale du travail
réformée ce n'est pas réduire le smic
réformer ce n'est pas cassé notre modèle
social où il ya la réforme non à
l'austérité manuel valls se veut
rassurant et réplique à la provocation
que constitue à ses yeux les récentes
propositions du medef il en profite au
passage pour annoncer une revalorisation
du minimum vieillesse une prime
exceptionnelle pour les petites
retraites et une baisse d'impôt pour 6
millions de français et manuel valls de
conclure avec une note de détermination
ma seule mission c'est d'avancer avancée
contre vents et marées guidés par une
infinie bienveillance pour les français
guidés par ma passion de la france et le
sens de l'état avant d'assurer à sa
majorité que ce qui les unit est bien
plus fort que ce qui les distingue
vallini je voudrais avoir votre thé
moyens dans un instant sur ce qu'on a
appelé les frondeurs mais avant un mot
sur le discours du premier ministre est
ce que c'est le discours d'un manuel
vals d'un premier ministre socialiste
manuel valls est évidemment socialiste
depuis son plus jeune âge si je dire
sens où son engagement dès la fin de
l'adolescence d'ailleurs a été au parti
socialiste personne ne met en cause ses
convictions socialistes
ses convictions sont intacts sont
idéales que je partageais le même nous
avons tous le même idéal au parti
socialiste de justice sociale d'égalité
républicaine de solidarité de laïcité
et en même temps manuel valls comme moi
et d'autres nous sommes conscients des
réalités jaurès déjà disait qu'il
fallait aller vers l'idéal en tenant
compte du réel à partir du réel on ne
doit plus être dans l'incantation à
gauche vous surtout quand on gouverne il
faut se colleter à la réalité c'est ce
que fait mal a dit que la sarkozie
vouloir la confrontation à tout prix
avec la droite ça peut monter aussi qu'
on est vraiment de gauche c'est ça qu'il
a voulu montrer je veux cette
confrontation pour montrer qu de gauche
non nous avons une opposition qui n'est
pas toujours aussi constructive qu'on
souhaiterait même sur la réforme
territoriale on y reviendra mais
l'opposition elle est là il faut en
tenir compte et c'est vrai que le débat
est utile de ce point de vue parce que
ce qui fait le lit du front national et
de marine le pen c'est ce discours
tendant à dire ump ps c'est la même
chose ump s vous savez cette ce mot-là
cette invention du front national ce
n'est pas vrai et l'ump à des
propositions très différentes des nôtres
l'ump propose un plan d'économie de 100
à 150 milliards ce serait une purge mais
terrible pour la société française pour
beaucoup d'acquis sociaux de la
convocation des cadres qu'il faut que la
droite
retrouve voilà ce que nous ferions nous
devrait dire l'ump parce que dire faire
des économies il faut faire plus
d'économies plus de réformes lesquels
c'est ça que veut manuel valls que la
droite dise ce qu'elle ferait à notre
place nous nous voyons les français
voient ce que nous faisons nous voulons
savoir ce que la droite ferait notre
place je pense qu'elle est bien embêté
pour ça vous avez une contestation à
l'intérieur du parti doit pas l'ignorer
ya quand même beaucoup d'abstention
beaucoup plus que oui mais ça fait quand
même trois fois plus que lors du premier
vote de confiance est ce qu'est ce que
voulez vous la prenez en compte est ce
que vous redoutez que qu'elle s'amplifie
lors du vote du budget
bien sûr le budget en europe par exemple
maintenant le mien fait consensus au
parti socialiste et à droite la révolte
hérite orcières sirugue et est accepté
par beaucoup mais sur le budget c'est
vrai qu'il va y avoir des discussions
manuel valls ne veut pas de négociations
on ne négocie pas avec des gens du même
parti que soit mais qu'on discute on
essaie d'amendé si les frondeurs comme
on les appelle propos des amendements
dans le cadre budgétaire qui sera tracée
par le gouvernement bien sûr qu'il
faudra en discuter voire en accepter
certains moi je suis quelqu'un d'ouvert
non seulement par rapport à l'opposition
ça a été dit par des parlementaires tout
à l'heure mais aussi par rapport
évidemment est d'abord par rapport à des
parlementaires socialistes dans tous les
domaines il faut discuter le
gouvernement et le parlement doivent
discuter
ce qui est curieux dans ce pays c'est
que si la majorité le parti majoritaire
obéit comme un seul homme le petit doigt
sur la couture du pantalon ont traité
parlementaire de godillots si les
parlementaires essaient de lire nos noms
n'est pas vraiment d'accord avec ça on
ferait plus plus gros cerfs autrement ou
dire oui alors c'est le désordre le
premier ministre ne tient pas sa
majorité le bon réglage ils étaient
entre les deux autres volumes y écouter
d'ailleurs les témoignages d'un
frondeurs est-ce qu'on va a fait d'un
dentier fraudeurs mais
vote de confiance c'est pas de juger
simplement la qualité d'un homme
d'habitude un discours c'est de donner
son assentiment non à une politique qui
allait annoncer et très franchement il y
manquait beaucoup de chance écoutez les
formes de réseaux notamment un bond très
bien fender il ya beaucoup de jeunes qui
sont amers de plus à pour gouverner
maintenant à moi c'est les français une
baisse c'est pas les promeneurs oui pas
mal d'annoncés qui ont été faites par
par manuel valls pas forcément dans le
discours de politique générale mais
plutôt le lendemain notamment cette
tranche d'impôt sur le revenu qui
devrait disparaître la première tranche
c'était quand même un sentiment
d'improvisation permanente n'ai pas
l'impression que alors là encore c'est
curieux dans notre pays si un nouveau
dispositif général et la 6ème année
quelque chose si un gouvernement ne mène
aucune réforme et donc ne fait aucune
annonce on dit que c'est de
l'immobilisme quand on gouverne quand un
gouvernement commençait la communication
c'est d'ailleurs que tu as à pau il va y
avoir des baisses d'impôts quant aux
gones en réformes ils annoncent ces
réformes il les met en eux ont dit c'est
de l'improvisation non le gouvernant il
agit tous les jours tous les jours le
gouvernement doit adapter au plus sa
politique à la conjoncture qui n'est pas
à vous l'avez remarqué aussi favorable
que nous souhaiterions la communication
ce que ça me servira sur sa gauche c'est
pour donner des gages à ces fameux
frondeurs non ce ne supporte pas de
gages aux frondeurs on explique aux
contribuables français qu'on les a
beaucoup sollicité depuis deux ans et
qu'on va maintenant flat alléger l'impôt
oui qui va financer qui va payer ça est
à l'étude tout ça est à l'étude et c'est
mon collègue christian eckert qui lui
aussi a une tâche difficile qui c'est à
lui de maîtriser
leur tendu quatre quand on interroge les
parlementaires sénateurs ou députés nous
dise ce seront forcément les classes
moyennes qui finiront par payer ce sont
les gens les plus favorisés bien sûr et
pas forcément les classes moyennes les
grilles gens vraiment favorisés qui
seront peut-être mis à contribution pour
dix ans logique c'est logique ça paraît
logique en matière de solidarité
nationale notamment sur le plan fiscal
on demande plus à ceux qui ont plus pour
alléger ceux qui ont le moins
je n'en sais rien les choses sont à
l'étude
c'est aux secrétaires d'état du budget
que les choses se passent pas dans mon
ministère alors parlons d'une réforme
qui vous concerne directement une autre
annonce de manuel valls qui n'est pas
passée inaperçue elle concerne la
réforme territoriale
les élections départementales auront
lieu en mars 2015 elles seront des
couples et des régionales qu'il se
tiendront elles fin 2015 parole de
manuel valls n'a nouvelle perte de
france est en cours d'élaboration sujet
casse tête pour le gouvernement et pour
vous andré vallini comme nous le montre
ce sujet de jérémy hartmann
c'est un énième changement de braquet
dans une réforme territoriale désormais
à trois vitesses pour 2020 manuel valls
propose que dans les départements dotés
d'une métropole les instances
départementales fusionne avec le
territoire métropolitain
une annonce qui n'a pas manqué de faire
réagir le président du conseil général
du val-de-marne christian favier je
considère le département est tout aussi
utile en zone urbaine dense qu'en zone
rurale et que les métropoles n'ont pas
vocation à remplacer les départements
les métropoles doivent s'occuper de
danger très stratégique et pas s'occuper
des compétences de proximité kayser ces
départements on a besoin
d'un échelon intermédiaire entre la
métropole et la commune et cet échange
le département autres mutations dans les
départements composé d'intercommunalité
forte entendez des communes de plus de
20 mille habitants structuré entre elles
les compétences départementales pourront
être transférées à une fédération
d'intercommunalité enfin et c'est une
mesure que didier guillaume président du
groupe socialiste au sénat avait proposé
en juillet dernier
dans les départements notamment ruraux
où les communautés de communes
n'atteignent pas la masse critique
le conseil départemental sera maintenu
avec des compétences clarifier une masse
critique qui est fixé à moins de 5000
habitants au sénat bruno sido constate
le bon sens retrouver de manuel valls
des départements ruraux sauver pourtant
la réforme pourrait être morte-née
souhaite un objet non identifié
et par conséquent si dans la loi un
autre on l'a on fait la différence entre
les départements dits ruraux les
départements dits structurés et les
départements dits métropolitain
peut-être que le conseil constitutionnel
ne retrouvera pas
finalement les idées qui me préval à
l'égalité des collectivités tout
simplement pour les scrutins au moins
les choses sont désormais claires manuel
valls précise que les élections
départementales auront lieu en mars 2015
quant aux régionales elles se tiendront
fin 2015 voilà lors les choses sont
apparemment clair pour les départements
par les liens des départements et elles
n'ont pas des communes elles sont
claires pour le pour le cese la date des
élections est ce que c'est aussi clair
pour le calendrier andré vallini est ce
que pouvait nous garantir nous sommes en
mars 2015 les élections ont lieu est-ce
que vous pouvez nous garantir que le
texte sur les départements et passer au
parlement quel est le calendrier le
calendrier est inchangé le premier
ministre l'a rappelé jeudi matin en
réunion des ministres à matignon nous
examinerons le projet de loi sur les
compétences en novembre au sénat et en
décembre à l'assemblée s'est fixé ça
c'est sûr enfin sous réserve de l'ordre
du jour qui est fixé par les par les
deux chambres et par le gouvernement
mais est tel que c'était prévu
les choses devraient se passer comme ça
et puis sur le projet de loi de cartes
régionales les choses vont se passer
aussi normalement deuxième lecture est
prévue à l'automne sans doute en octobre
au sénat et en novembre à l'assemblée la
réforme est gigantesque
vous aurez acheté tous vos toutes vos
consultations tous les textes je ne fais
que ça les consultations justement c'est
pour ça que certains parlementaires ne
trouve qu'on ne voit pas assez dans les
couloirs de l'assemblée ou du sénat moi
je travaille à mon bureau et dans les
rayons aussi qui ont lieu ailleurs qu'à
mon bureau et notamment en province je
consulte beaucoup j'écoute beaucoup
parce que c'est très fort je le répète
elle ne demande la concertation elle est
évolutive vous le voyez elle est
progressive elle va s'étaler sur
plusieurs années et sur les départements
notamment ce que je veux bien faire
comprendre à nos auditeurs et aux élus
locaux en particulier les départements
les conseils généraux vont demeurer en
place 2015 à au moins 2020 nous allons
être élu ou réélu moi même je vais être
à nouveau candidat dans mon camp tôt
nous allons être élu en 2015 pour cinq
ans donc nous avons cinq ans pour voir
ce que deviennent les conseils généraux
je rassure par l'un des sénateurs les
cotisations c'est ce que voulait dire
non aux expérimentations ça ça peut
exister moi même je vais lancer des
expérimentations dans mon département
oui entre 2015 et 2020 mais ce qui est
prévu dans la loi et nous sommes en
train de préparer c'est que nous allons
transférer des compétences
départementales aux régions voirie les
routes transports notamment scolaires
collèges le développement économique
tout ça va être transférée aux régions
et les transferts auront lieu entre 2016
et 2017 progressivement tard est
progressif mais pour le reste les
compétences les plus importantes des
conseils généraux c'est à dire le social
comme on dit rapidement personnes âgées
personnes handicapées le rsa les
familles en difficulté la pmi protection
maternelle et infantile l'enfance en
danger l'enfance maltraitée hélas
importante est là qu est la solidarité
territoriale entre les territoires
favoriser et ceux qui le sont moins tout
ça ça reste du domaine des conseils
généraux de 2015 à 2025 les conseils
généraux restent et pour jusqu'en 2020
ou là aujourd'hui mardi on a cinq ans
pour réfléchir à l'évolution
générale 2 manuel wandji à l'assemblée
nationale qui agit
généraux reprenait la phrase attaques de
manuel valls il a dit je propose
d'ouvrir le débat sur la suppression
était refermée non le débat il a lieu la
preuve on en parle aujourd'hui on va en
parler pendant cinq ans va le manuel
valls a dit je propose qu'on ouvre le
débat sur la suppression des conseils
généraux il a ajouté j'y suis favorable
mais il a voulu au débat le débat a lieu
la suppression des conseils vers le but
de cette réforme finalement c'est aussi
de faire des économies l'état en
recherche désespérément est ce que vous
pouvez me donner un chiffre il y en a
beaucoup qui circule partout au point de
s'y perdre est-ce que vous donner un
chiffre on va donner un chien chaque
personne peut donner un chiffre
d'économie il ya beaucoup d'estimations
remettrai
je vais vous donner des exemples plutôt
qu'un chiffre tout le monde sait que
cette réforme va faire des économies va
permettre de faire des économies mais
d'abord sur le moyen et long terme pas
dans les six mois pendant les deux ou
trois ans qui viennent pour une fois on
fait une réforme structurelle ce que
demande la droite à cor et à cri
d'ailleurs quand on est à la droite
laquelle voulez vous en priorité ils
disent la réforme territoriale et quand
on leur propose la réforme territoriale
bizarre non pas comme ça pas celle ci
pas maintenant pas tant qu'on fait une
forme structurelles sur le long terme on
sort du court termisme de lune et dans
le guidon c'est le court termisme qui
fait tant de mal à la politique et au
journalisme aussi donc là on essaie de
voix le voir loin de voir grand de voir
loin sur 5 à 10 ans en ayant réformé
toutes les strates communes
intercommunalités syndicats de communes
qu'il faut supprimer en grande partie
départements régions en fusionnant en
restructurant en supprimant les doublons
en mutualisant les moyens en faisant des
économies d'échelle on peut faire des
milliards d'économies mais pas avant dix
ans et après avoir tout réformer voilà
ce qui est logique ce qui est
raisonnable de questions sur cette
fameuse carte des régions la première à
ce que vous ne craignez pas que cette
réforme est un impact sur les futures
élections sénatoriales qui ont lieu dans
une semaine à peu près ce que vous ne
craignez pas que s'assigne la défaite de
la gauche au sénat d'euros parce que
beaucoup d'amis sénateurs les ex
collègues du sénat que j'aime beaucoup
les collègues et le sénat parce que
c'est une maison ont fait du bon travail
de qualité on approfondit les choses
donc beaucoup de sénateurs en campagne
notamment de sénateurs socialistes le
disent une inquiétude sur la réforme
territoriale
on répond aux inquiétudes on a des
réponses à apporter aux interrogations
la réforme territoriale reste encore un
peu flou chez les locaux il ya quelque
chose il faut le reconnaître qu'ils
posent problème et qui demandent des
arguments et qui demande des
explications
ce sont les fameux rythme scolaire ça il
est vrai que dans les petites communes
tous les candidats en campagne sénateur
candidat en campagne dit ce qu'on le
repas on leur parle beaucoup des rythmes
scolaires c'est une bonne réforme dans
l'intérêt de l'enfant mais qui c'est
vrai pose quelques problèmes financiers
aux petites communes et ma deuxième
question si pendant l'examen en octobre
de la deuxième lecture l'ump propose une
nouvelle carte d'un jour etes-vous prêts
aujourd'hui à l'examiner est donc
possible de ne plus voir treize régions
mais 12 13 ou 14 par exemple on joue une
nouvelle architecture vous êtes vous
allée jean pierre raffarin propose huit
ou neuf je crois donc ça va saigner sur
quelques chiffres là encore
le dernier mot c'est le parlement qui
est souverain donc c'est le sénat et
l'assemblée nationale qui à la fin
votera en définitive la carte la
nouvelle carte régionale nous avons
toujours dit que nous étions prêts au
dialogue et j'ai été d'ailleurs assez
malheureux qu'au sénat le dialogue ne
puisse pas s'engager mais je me souviens
des paroles de jean pierre raffarin a
notamment qui nous avait dit en deuxième
lecture les choses se passeront mieux il
avait jugé je résume en substance parce
que les élections seront derrière nous
et c'est vrai que en première lecture au
sénat on sentait bien la concurrence
entre monsieur marini monsieur rappaz
ramos élargirait peux-tu ranchère on est
prêt à aller jusqu'où le parlement
souhaitera qu'on a il faut que le
parlement nous dise quelle carte
régionale il souhaite nous avions
proposé une carte qui n'a pas été celle
qui a été votée finalement par
l'assemblée nationale donc nous avons
respecté et évidemment et heureusement
les droits du parlement l'assemblée à
une zone à votre interdite on n'est pas
dans le chiffrage est forcément on est
dans la cohérence nouveau des grandes
régions cohérente puissante attractif
parce que l'objet de la réforme avant de
faire des économies et il faut faire
c'est de clarifier les compétences entre
les communes les départements les
régions c'est aussi de rendre les
territoires et notamment les régions
plus attractive plus compétitives au
plan international dans la concurrence
que se livrent que se livrent tous les
territoires d'europe et même du monde
pour attirer les investisseurs donc le
premier objectif c'est la clarté le
deuxième c'est la compétitivité c'est
les régions le troisième c'est des
services publics efficaces et proche des
gens ce sont les intercommunalités et
puis les économies budgétaires qui
viendront en conséquence andré vallini
on va passer sur un autre sujet mais
c'était mercredi également l'assemblée
nationale et un ministre qui a fait son
baptême du feu c'est emmanuel micro il a
dû s'expliquer à l'assemblée nationale
sur une petite phrase malheureuse au
sujet des salariés de gad qu'il a
qualifié d' illettré il a dû présenter
ses excuses écouter
le premier regret c'est pour les propos
que j'ai tenus ce matin
si j'ai blessé et parce que j'ai blessé
des salariés et c'est inacceptable et ça
n'est pas ce que je voulais faire
si vous écoutez ce que j'ai pu dire ce
matin à madame je prenais cet exemple
précisément parce qu'il est une
injustice tout point exemplaire parce
que précisément cet exemple de gad pour
lequel plusieurs députés ici se sont
battus dans cette majorité pour lequel
stéphane le foll ici s'est battu c'est
que ces salariés n'ont pas eu la
formation et la formation continue qu'il
était en droit d'attendre c'est parce
que souvent et nous précisément pas eu
c'était l'exemple que je voulais prendre
le permis de conduire qu'on doit leur
donner
et donc nos premiers regrets mes excuses
les plus plates elles vont à l'égard des
salariés que j'ai pu blesser que j'ai
blessé à travers ses propos et je ne
m'en excuserai jamais assez il est trés
ça vous a choqué le mot était
l'expression était maladroite et plus
que ça à la blesser donc je trouve que
emmanuel macron a bien fait de s'excuser
et c'est beaucoup excusé c'est rare de
voir un homme politique s'excuser à ce
point donc dont acte la page est tournée
il a commis une erreur est une erreur
qui effectivement a blessé beaucoup les
salariés de gad et on les comprend mais
en même temps le problème qu'a posée
emmanuel macron c'est le problème de
l'illettrisme
c'est peut-être ça le plus important au
delà de la réparation morale qu'il a
apportées aux salariés blessés il
fallait le faire
le preuve c'est l'illettrisme or depuis
quelques années à quoi at on assisté à
une diminution des crédits consacrés à
la lutte contre l'illettrisme sous le
gouvernement précédent de 2007 à 2012
les crédits de lutte contre
l'illettrisme ont reculé donc c'est bien
de demander à
avant de s'excuser mais il faut surtout
lutter contre l'illettrisme je propose
de passer au jeudi auprès vallini et
cette fois le président de la république
qui s'expriment devant 400 journalistes
le face à face était attendu françois
hollande devant ce grand oral de vaud
400 journalistes président a longuement
évoqué la situation internationale
économique et c'est également un petit
peu livrés marie brémaud développe avec
nous les mots du président
il y à un mot que françois hollande a
particulièrement affectionner durant
cette conférence de presse françois
hollande un homme des choix c'est
pourquoi j'ai fait des choix j'ai choisi
manuel valls j'ai fait le choix aussi de
l'innovation et de la transformation et
choix ils sont en même temps conforme à
ce que je vis j'ai fait le choix de la
république enfants et les choix du chef
de l'état par le passé mais également
pour l'avenir ce sont des réformes des
réformes des réformes
j'ai pas de faire des réformes pour
défendre là vous avez parfaitement
raison tout le monde veut faire des
réformes tout le monde a les réformes
pour les réformes ça fait plaisir eh
bien oui j'ai fait toutes ces réformes
mais le président de la république
devant le parterre de journalistes a
fait part également de ses états d'âme
au travers d'une figure de style qui lui
est cher l'anaphore première pas facile
quand on a été élu pas facile d'aller
demander d impôt supplémentaire c'est
pas facile de faire des réformes sur le
marché du travail c'est pas facile pas
facile de faire la réforme territoriale
deuxième c'est dur c'est dur c'est dur
très dur pour moi mais ce qui m'a paru
le plus nécessaire c'est d'être dur
d'abord avec moi même confessions d'un
homme sincère ou stratégie de
communication françois hollande aura en
tout cas tout tenté pour faire remonter
sa cote de popularité
alors comment cette conférence de presse
at elle été reçue dans l'opinion on va
s'arrêter aussi sur les mots du discours
c'est le zone de parlement hebdo
frédéric dabi nous a rejoints sur ce
plateau bonjour bonjour vous êtes
directeur général adjoint de l'ifop
observateurs de la vie politique alors
on va vous poser la question mais
d'abord une question avoue andré vallini
entrée théâtrale du président de la
république ministre quasiment au
garde-à-vous face à 500 journalistes est
ce que pendant ce genre d'exercice n'est
pas un peu passé de mode à quoi ça sert
ces grandes messes évidemment ça sert
d'abord à tenir un engagement celui qui
avait pris françois hollande de faire
une conférence de presse tous les six
mois à l'époque vous aviez trouvé ça
plutôt bien vous les journalistes parce
que si même les journalistes me ment et
commencent à contester le fact et des
conférences de presse
ça pose un vrai problème enfin bref si
vous je pense que journaliste devrait
apprécier qui est des conférences de
presse mais il a tenu cet engagement
c'est la quatrième en deux ans nicolas
sarkozy avait pris le même engagement
donné récemment dans la presse il en a
fait une en cinq ans sarkozy françois
hollande tient son engagement et sa
serre ça vous sert à lui poser des
questions il se met comme ça sur le
devant de la scène devant 300
journalistes dans un contexte très
difficile après les dernières semaines
qu'on a vécu eh bien il n'a pas reculé
l'échéance il a dit je ferai ma
conférence de presse je trouve que c'est
beaucoup de courage et ça permet
accessoirement ça permet quand même de
désinformation de refixer le cap d'avoir
de la hauteur dire aux français voilà où
je vous propose de continuer à aller le
redressement du pays et les réformes du
pays pour cette conférence de presse il
est trop tôt pour voir impact dans
l'opinion publique même si on sait très
bien qu'une conférence de presse quelle
qu'elle soit sociale a raté de nicolas
sarkozy en janvier 2008 d'ailleurs sa
seule
n'inverse pas une tendance de choses
clairement il a cherché à se
représidentialiser avec beaucoup de
propos sur la situation internationale
une véritable dramatisons comme l'a fait
manuel valls à l'assemblée nationale il
est clairement aussi sur une posture
sacrificielle j'irai jusqu'au bout je
suis président je ne suis pas candidat
il a remis son bilan en perspective il a
refixé le cas que ça c'est vrai mais
c'est vrai qu'il ya un changement de
pied entre le françois hollande que l'on
accède de trop optimistes avec la la
croissance est là le retournement
économique va se faire et là clairement
il a fait part de doute sur des
résultats avant 2010 est lorsqu'il a dit
par exemple les résultats s'ils peuvent
arrivé je les prendrai en espérant que
la conjoncture s'améliore on a senti du
doute de ce point de vue là mais c'est
clairement en continuité avec ses
exercices précédents l'anaphore encore
une fois c'est pas facile c'est dur
franchement c'était utile ça
je pense que ce n'est pas facile d'être
prison la république surtout dans le
contexte actuel hélas la conjoncture
économique qui c'est vrai est beaucoup
plus difficile que nous l'avions imaginé
le message mais pourquoi
devrait il pas joie ils parlent vrai il
dit que c'est difficile de réformer la
france sur la réforme quand je dis moi
que la réforme territoriale tout le
monde la veut depuis des années mais que
quand on propose de la faire les
résistants sion si vous dites qu'il est
là pour donner le cap ce qui donne un
peu d'optimisme et la pression que les
chimistes non il a donné le cap on
continue les réformes même si c'est
difficile et on continue à redresser le
pays même si c'est difficile car
justement frédéric dabi est ce que ce
que dit andré vallini reconnaître pour
un président que c'est difficile est ce
que ça ça peut avoir un impact un impact
sur l'opinion sur ce qui peut être
mortifère c'est un aveu d'impuissance on
se souvient de la conférence de presse
était pas le cas hier il a plutôt fait
part des difficultés et c'est vrai que
ça peut sur trop optimisme la reprise
est là ça lui avait fait très mal et ça
avait décrédibiliser démonétisé un peu
la parole présidentielle le fait de
reconnaître des des difficultés me
paraît moins gênant non peut être d'une
part il a très peu a annoncé les choses
sauf en sur la situation internationale
peut-être aussi faut-il s'interroger sur
la longueur de l'exercice et sur
l'articulation avec un premier ministre
qui a peut-être saturer l'espace
médiatique
lors de son discours de politique
générale et sur divers médias et qui a
peut-être laissé un peu moins d'espacé
que prévu au président de ce point de
vue là on n'a pas été dans la logique de
la cinquième en hiver justement écouter
le président de la république au sujet
de sa relation avec le premier ministre
si vous regardez la vie politique tout
est envisageable
si vous regardez manuel valls et moi ce
n'est pas envisageable
parce que j'ai choisi manuel valls
pour ses qualités pour son courage il en
a deux la fait preuve pour
son sens de l'état et pour sa loyauté
et je sais que jusqu'au bout il servira
l'état andré vallini françois hollande
s'occupe de l'international manuel valls
du reste
il ya une différence évidemment de rôle
entre le président et le premier
ministre c'est comme ça sous la vème
république le président fixe le cap en
politique intérieure annonce les grandes
réformes et puis ensuite c'est au
premier ministre est bien de mettre en
oeuvre les réformes et de tenir le cap
maintenant sur l'international c'est
vrai que françois hollande et sa
personne ne lui conteste assume
totalement son rôle de chef de l'état de
chef des armées de chef de la diplomatie
de l'un des pays membres du conseil de
sécurité des nations unies ce que nous
avons fait au mali ce que nous allons
faire en irak tout ça est vraiment digne
du rôle que noah que de jouer la france
tient parfaitement le rôle de chef de
l'état au niveau international alors il
ya un autre président dont on a parlé
dans le françois hollande a parlé sans
dire son nom un hoax ex président
nicolas sarkozy son retour était sur
toutes les lèvres sans que son nom soit
prononcé jamais
il ne m'appartient pas comme président
de la république
de commenter les éventuelles
déclarations de candidatures à la
direction d'un parti et notamment du
premier parti d'opposition
il ya plus de suspense apparemment le
retour de nicolas sarkozy semble acté
qu'est ce que ça change pour la gauche
est ce que c'est une aubaine au
contraire
non mais d'abord est ce qu'il est
vraiment parti un jour franchement
depuis deux ans nicolas sarkozy se
rappellent sans arrêt bons souvenirs
enfin bon entre guillemets au bon
souvenir des français moi je pense qu'il
n'est jamais vraiment parti je pense
deuxième manque il a toujours voulu
revenir
au premier rang de la scène politique et
comme candidat à la présidentielle donc
pour moi ce n'est pas une surprise je
veux dire deux choses il est parti en
laissant la france en mauvais état et
l'ump en mauvais état aussi donc il veut
revenir s'occuper de l'ump très bien
qu'ils le fassent pour ce qui est de la
france c'est à nous de remettre la
france sur les rails et de et de la
redresser et on s'y attaque tous les
jours et puis la deuxième la deuxième
chose que je veux dire c'est que il a
peut être un avenir politique à l'ump en
tout cas c'est aux militants de l'ump
d'en décider et il a aussi un avenir
judiciaire parce que son nom est cité
dans beaucoup d'affaires il est présumé
innocent c'est clair mais c'est à lui de
pouvoir concilier s'il y arrive son
avenir politique éventuel et son avenir
judiciaire
ces affaires sont elles un obstacle au
retour
nicolas sarkozy non les français ne se
pose pas la question comme ça c'est vrai
que sur nicolas sarkozy ya deux niveaux
de lecture ya l'ensemble des français
qui fait le même diagnostic que monsieur
vallini ou on n'attend pas nicolas
sarkozy on a le sentiment qu'une et
vraiment je vais partie avec ses vraies
fausses cartes postales il n'a pas fait
comme martine aubry qui elle pendant
deux ans a vraiment affaire vrai silence
médiatique et c'est vrai que du côté des
français il n'ya pas d'appétence et de
désir d'un retour de nicolas sarkozy une
dernière enquête ifop fiducial pour
paris match et sud radio montré que deux
tiers des français ne souhaitait pas
être candidat à la présidentielle de
2017 mais il ya la france des
sympathisants ump qu'il a c'est vrai
n'est resté très sarko de staël gic qui
a beaucoup apprécié les cartes postales
et le fait que nicolas sarkozy ne les
abandonne pas une france des
sympathisants ump
très sévère depuis le début du
quinquennat sur françois hollande pas la
moindre bienveillance quand une partie
de la gauche en 2007 pour nicolas
sarkozy et alec l'attend avec une
impatience avait quand même 2 vraie
inconnue son bilan qui va perdre qui est
qui a été un vrai boulet pour lui en fin
de mandat et qui va permettre à la
gauche et à la majorité présidentielle
de rejouer le levier de l'héritage et
puis l'incertitude sur les questions
judiciaires fatal est allé voir où
l'attendra le match retour entre
invalides et ses pommettes remercie
beaucoup vous ferez des avec damien vaut
rester avec lui d'abord validé on va
parler de justice est un domaine que
vous connaissez bien et plus
particulièrement des juges
on va parler d'un juge renaud van
ruymbeke ce nom évidemment vous avez
déjà certainement entendu parler il a la
main sur les dossiers très très
politique c'est un documentaire diffusé
sur france 3 cette semaine qui revient
sur trottant denquête judiciaire simon
barbarie l'a vu pour nous regarder
l'égalité devant la loi c'est quelque
chose pour moi qui me sert un petit
fondamentale on le voit peu devant les
caméras pourtant son nom est associé aux
grandes affaires politico financières de
ces trente dernières années le juge
anti-corruption renaud van ruymbeke est
le sujet d'un documentaire diffusé sur
france 3 cette semaine onno van ruymbeke
au nom de la loi de philippe pichon
n'est pas le portrait d'un homme d'un
juge mais plutôt celui d'une république
ou justice et pouvoir font rarement bon
ménage
c'est presqu'un un débat républicain
faut si c'est pas parce que quelqu'un
est élu qu'il a tous les droits qui le
dessus des lois
ou alors faut le dire
si on est dans une dictature feu dire
lors d'entretiens inédits
le juge évoque sans détour les affaires
marquantes de sa carrière de l' affaire
boulin à la sphère claire stream en
passant par le financement du parti
socialiste et du parti républicain
autant de dossiers qui lui ont valu les
foudres de la sphère politique
souvent ils essayent les attaques
personnelles contre la personne du juge
bien entendu si le juge s'intéresse à
nous c'est parce que il a des îles à des
arrière pensées
ils ont pas une chance parce que dans
mon parcours
j'ai eu la gauche la droite alors faut
pas taxer de l'aide à côté ou de l'autre
bien plus que les attaques personnelles
dont il a fait l'objet c'est cette
culture de soumission du monde
judiciaire au pouvoir qui nous
interpelle le juge van ruymbeke nous
invite alors à une réflexion sur l'état
de notre contrat social l'inégalité
devant la loi et le discrédit de la
classe politique qui l'accompagnent une
musique inquiétante qui n'a pas fini de
faire échos
andré vallini est ce que le juge van
ruymbeke dont le nom est associé à trets
toutes ces affaires qu'on a revu est-ce
que ce juge est juste une époque révolue
pourquoi au contraire une pour moi le
juge van ruymbeke pour qui j'ai la plus
grande estime
de l'estiment qui confine même a de
l'admiration pour son indépendance
d'esprit son travail remarquable sur
beaucoup d'affaires mais pour son
indépendance d'esprit ça sa rectitude
professionnelle et donc morale moi je
les rencontre et
je voulais le rencontrer je voulais
parler avec lui de justice et il m'a
impressionné parce qu'en plus il a de
l'humour quand ont déjeuné avec lui on
s'aperçoit que c'est quelqu'un qui a de
l'humour et à le voir comme ça c'est pas
ce qui frappe au premier abord donc
c'est quelqu'un d'immensément
respectable et pour répondre à votre
question c'est pas le jus d'une époque
révolue c'est au contrat pour moi ce que
d'être un juge aujourd'hui et demain
indépendant exemple un exemple un
exemple bien sûr pour tous les élèves
magistrats de l'école de bordeaux de
l'école de la magistrature c'est son
indépendance qui doit forcer
l'admiration bien sûr c'est un modèle et
je crois que avec des personnalités
comme ça dans le monde judiciaire et
pourquoi pas dans le monde politique
aussi on peut réconcilier les français
avec avec l'amour delà des nouvelles à
sa mission avec l'amour de la république
parce que vous avez vu évidemment vous
avez été certainement aussi très
fragilisé aussi parce qu'il s'est passé
que la sphère techno et ce problème que
les élus au dessus des lois c'est ce que
les français ne veulent plus mais les
élus ne sont pas au dessus des lois et
je personnellement comme tous mes
collègues honnête nous n'avons pas été
fragilisée par la ferté nous d'affaires
et nous a montré qu'il ya dans
l'incorporation politique comme dans
toutes les corporations des gens qui ne
paient pas leurs impôts qui fraudent qui
triche il faut les détecter l'essentiel
c'est de détecter de les sanctionner et
de les éliminer entre guillemets et bien
de la vie politique en gouvernementale
pour ce qui concerne thomas thévenoud il
faut aussi voir non pas le bon côté des
choses mais l'aspect positif du fait
qu'aujourd'hui on arrive très rapidement
a détecté un ministre qui ne paie pas
ses impôts et il n'est plus au
gouvernement donc
on a l'impression pas ce qu'il va faire
tourner ou qu'un nouveau toute la classe
politique sera mise en cause mais non
pas du tout mais pas ça
le mode sport merci andré vallini
d'avoir été l'invité de parlement hebdo
merci quatre heures on se retrouve la
semaine prochaine à une bonne semaine à
tous